so in this video we're going to think
about dividing numbers where the
quotient the result of our division
might result in a decimal so let's say
we wanted to compute what 5/2 is in the
past you might have said hey 2 times 2
is 4 and then you have 1 left over and
so you might have said something like
this this is 2 with a remainder of 1 but
now we don't want we wanted to say hey
how many times can it go in and what's
left over we want to know exactly how
many times can to go into 5 so we want a
decimal answer right over here so pause
this video and see if you can figure
that out
all right now let's work through this
together and there's many ways that we
can approach this one way is to realize
that 5 divided by 2 we can re-express as
5 divided by 2 or as 5 halves and 5
halves is the same thing as 4 plus 1
over 2 which is the same thing as 4
halves plus 1/2 which is the same thing
as 4 halves is to let me do that in a
different color this part over here is 2
and then you have this 1/2 so it's the
same thing as 2 and 1/2 and if we were
to express that as a decimal that's
going to be equal to 2 and how many
tenths is equal to 1/2 well 5 tenths is
equal to 1/2 so 5 divided by 2 you could
say is 2.5 now another way that you
could approach this is you say 5 divided
by 2 is the same thing as 50 tenths
divided by 2 so let me use a different
color here so instead of a 5 I could say
5 is the same thing as 50 tenths 50
tenths divided by divided by 2 and so if
I have 50 of something and if I were to
divide it in by 2 well that's going to
result in 25 of the something so this is
going to be equal to 25 tenths and how
would we express 25 tenths as a decimal
well this is going to be equal to I
could put some place values here so we
definitely have 5 tenths I'll put that
in the tenths place
and then 20 tenths 20 tenths is the same
thing as two ones and that's exactly
what we had up here either way you get
to point five two ones and five tenths